imagine being able to open any difficult
book ignore all distractions and
understand it
immediately we might not be able to do
this but we definitely seem to be
expected to with every passing Year my
books seem to get harder and distraction
stronger I've always been a speed reader
but with hard topics the issue isn't how
fast my eyes read words I'm limited by
my comprehension tiredness and drifting
Focus eventually feeling slow and stupid
so what if I told you I've found a way
you can increase the speed with which
you understand very difficult texts and
it's through never being allowed to
speedread adding a bunch of extra stuff
to the words and retraining the reading
voice in your head let me show you how
to train your brain your focus and your
eyes for advanced speed reading training
your brain the playright technique let's
say I gave you this text and told you
you have 5 Seconds to tell me what it's
about did you read the block of text at
the top or did your eyes skim the
dialogue first probably the latter our
brains love dialogue and story studies
show that we are much quicker at reading
stories than informational text and with
dialogue specifically we are much
quicker at reading and understanding
direct quotes than indirect quotes even
when they have the exact same words
characters plots and story lines make
things much easier for our brains to
grasp to benefit from this you can teach
yourself to turn any sort of text into a
Story in real time all you need to do is
retrain the reading voice in your head
if like me you always read out loud in
your head there's not just one way to do
it if you're still using the way that we
were taught as children to read the text
word for word in your head like you
would a novel you're not only going to
be reading informational books slower
you're also going to be understanding
them a lot slower the reason being when
you do things this way you first have to
tell your brain out loud the words that
are on the text then you need to ask
yourself what it means and then you need
to explain to yourself what you think it
might mean because these texts are
difficult abstract and nonvisual it's
very easy to feel like you are stupid
and slow when you're reading in this way
so this is what I do instead when
reading something complex I picture
myself as a playwright I think I've been
given Source material and I need to turn
it into a play I don't think of
understanding abstract Concepts and
information I think of characters plot
lines stories visuals the scene very
crucially the voice in my head is not
reading out the words on the paper my
eyes are looking at the words but the
voice in my head is only speaking the
new story that I am creating so let me
show you what this looks like in real
time let's say I'm reading the
echocardiography of heartbe failure this
is quite an abstract and semi complex
topic this is what I would do if I was
reading the first paragraph So I have my
sick hard failed heart on the scene and
it has these valves which have gotten
narrower and sometimes they are like
calcified and hard and thicker and now
we also have this Doppler which is like
an ultrasound machine which is my second
character and when the Doppler sends
these ultrasound waves towards the heart
then it's going to have these loud
Echoes of course cuz the valves are
harder they're not going to be as
flexible and moving as well so now this
Doppler machine has come on and it's
going to check what the pressure is in
the chambers on both s sides of these
damaged valves now this Doppler ound is
really professional and super sensitive
and it can check if the blood is going
in the wrong direction through the
valves now the specific type of heart
failure which is when the heart muscle
has gotten really really loose on on
both sides of these valves it's loose
both when the heart is resting and
that's when it's like on holiday and
it's also loose when the heart has just
come back from like a contraction so a
workout and this means that because it's
been um like really widened these
muscles are looser these Chambers are
bigger and it doesn't have that
elasticity that the heart used to have
when it was younger so it doesn't get as
small and big as it should be so the
general theme of what I do in these
cases is I will humanize specific
characters in the story so it can be the
heart has decisions to make and
characteristics and feelings and choices
and consequences it can be electrons can
feel this way so by being a character
it's much more easy for me to think of
what they're doing to add extra
dimensions of making sense in my head
and much easier for me to visualize and
transform the text by completely
skipping my internal voice reading it's
rather focusing on creating this logical
breakdown on making sense of things and
giving them to me so that I can
understand this definitely can take
practice especially if you want to
become faster and faster at it but I
want to emphasize it's probably
something that we've all done to some
extent when we've read something that
doesn't make sense and we go wait wait
wait what do you mean or if you've ever
had The Misfortune like me of reading a
manual without images you're kind of
confused and you just go wait let me let
me let me break this down and you try to
create okay step one it does this then
it does this so it's the exact same
Instinct that we have for simplifying
things for visualizing them but just
leaning into it a lot more intentionally
to make this reading faster now between
my studies for University and research
for this YouTube videos the amount of
information and text that I need to go
through on a daily basis and see and
speedread and organize and save and keep
is insane and it's absolutely essential
for me to have a really really tight and
good organizational system to keep all
of this stuff so before I go on to
training our focus and training our eyes
I want to show you where a lot of this
information
sits and how I organize it online now as
a bit of a productivity organizational
and reading junkie I've tried and use so
many different apps to keep my things in
order but the one thing that I have
never changed since first using
computers over a decade ago is my web
browser I'm sort of person who non-reg
really always has 50 plus tabs open I
need everything to be there I hate
having to remember the name of a website
or the name of a paper or something that
I need to look at will just keep things
open all the time and I cannot shut them
because it FS me with so much guilt and
to be honest it's not a really sexy
conversation that people really talk
about shopping for web browsers but I'm
so so grateful that I was convinced by
the sponsor of this video doio sigos to
give them a go if your brain seems to
work anything like mine you really need
to give this at least the free trial a
quick go because it completely
transforms everything it's so intuitive
you can pick up the workflow within a
few minutes and to show my own personal
workflow and how I use it I've made a
separate private video link below that
you can watch if you want to have a peek
onto how I chaotically organize my
things because I really want to do it
justice and drive home the point of how
much this transforms your online work
and your reading and organizing things
online there's separate Works spaces for
absolutely everything all the Hat I need
to where student writer editor YouTuber
procrastinator all of these have their
different spaces all of the main
websites are locked in and stay there if
I want to open something that's already
open somewhere else Sigma will take me
to that tab rather than me having to
duplicate things again and again opening
and closing things is so much easier
things are organized in a logical way
where if you open a sub page it becomes
like underneath and not a main tap it's
insane it's incredible you can split
screen to check something really quickly
so you don't need to get distracted from
the main thing that you're working on
and all Google Chrome extensions
especially video speed controller for
making videos faster all work on it too
I have a link below that will give you
free access for trial and also that
video of my full workfl if you want to
have a look as to how these videos and
studying and things come together so now
let's get back to increasing our Focus
for speed reading difficult things
training your focus T is for troll it
does sound crazy but adding more words
to your text eventually makes you read
faster let me try to explain one of the
main reasons I stop reading difficult
things is because I just get bored it's
either too tiring or I'm not invested or
engaged enough and there's just much
more interesting things and what I do to
increase my focus and therefore to read
more is that when I feel that my focus
is dwindling and I'm about to quit I
will then become a Critic if the text is
being hard to me I will be difficult
right back as I'm reading something I
will start to judge the way that it's
written so I'll say in my head well that
makes absolutely no sense or why would
you phrase this this way this is the
absolute worst or oh my God that's such
a good way of making that point that's
incredible inedible or wait wait wait
wait how did you just say this where
where's your proof or you can't jump to
this conclusion without explaining it
beforehand oh my God and it sounds like
you don't even know what you're talking
about how am I supposed to understand
now these are value judgments on the
writers please forgive me an apologies
to all of them add another layer of
interaction with the text they put you
in the mindset of a teacher someone
who's criticizing someone's essay things
that I really need to do a lot when I
was a tutor I used the same sort of
harsh judgment on what they're saying
being hypocritical in this way makes me
hang on to every single word catching
them for a mistake or trying to prove to
them that they're saying something wrong
it increases my motivation and laser
focus on the words on the text but also
it helps me emotionally because instead
of feeling like I am helpless and stupid
for not understanding something I can
even though it's completely fake put
myself in the position of I am your
manager I am the book editor when you
sent this in and let me show you you how
you've written all of this wrong this
sort of like semi confidence boost
really helps with increasing focus and
is very necessary sometimes when dealing
with complicated things to learn at the
very least what he gives me is a few
extra minutes of focus and sometimes
that's all I need in order to understand
something or find the text interesting
again and it's this really good kind of
motivation and focus patch that can get
me going on for a lot longer three
training your eyes there is no going
back this might be the most
counterintuitive point of all but I'm
arguing that you need to train your eyes
to stop going back to the beginning of
the text when you haven't understood
something we've all had this habit I've
had it too where I read something I
wasn't paying attention or it was too
difficult or I just don't know and I go
through it and I'm like I have no idea
what I just read and my instinct then is
to go right back to the beginning of the
chapter or the beginning of whatever I
was reading and go through it again I
argue you should never ever ever do this
as this is so bad and I'll try to
explain why if you are thinking I don't
know what I just read or I don't know
what this is about or I don't understand
what's going on all of these in my
opinion are terrible reasons to go back
to the beginning of the text what I
argue that you should do instead is
power on and keep reading start paying
attention now keep reading until you
have a specific question until you have
wait how does this thing work then when
you have that question you can go back
to find specifically where the answer
for it is so rereading something just
because you weren't paying attention the
first time and have no clue is a bad
reason to go to the beginning you want
to have a specific question that you
want to answer and that's where you can
jump back to that part only the reason
for doing this is that having to redo
something which is semi-familiar is one
of the biggest causes of motivational
drop even in computers not just in
people we do not like to go back to the
beginning it is exhausting it is energy
draining and it really takes takes away
any sort of motivation that we have to
go through something we have reduced our
novelty even if we don't understand
anything our eyes have seen this again
they're not going to care and in the
long run if you keep jumping back and
back and back to the start your
motivation is going to be nowhere you're
going to trash every sort of Desire that
you initially had to get this thing done
and you're much more likely to close the
book and keep doing something else so
try to power on you will have missed out
on things but those gaps you can fill in
where they need to be and when you
understand why you need to know them in
the first place do not redo boring
things and even if you started reading
something a long time ago don't restart
it again start from where you stop and
then keep continue going to the back
when you really want to because this is
just a very very easy way to make
yourself more motivated to read longer
and eventually faster please do give me
any tips that you have for speed reading
or understanding things better or for
final your medical students because they
would be greatly greatly appreciated if
you made it so far thank you so much for
spending this time with me I hope you
have a wonderful rest of your day be
kind to yourself and others and do
believe everything you think thanks
bye